we all saw that gpt4 is able to create a
website from handwriting on a napkin
with all the news since the focus on
Vision has been lost meanwhile in the
last few hours and days a select few
with full access to multimodal gpt4 have
been releasing snapshots of what it can
do I want to show you not only what is
imminent with gpt4 vision but with
releases this week in text to 3D text
inside 3D speech to text and even
embodiment we're gonna see how language
and visual model Innovations are
complementing each other and beginning
to snowball but let's start with images
do you remember from the gpt4 technical
report when the model was able to
manipulate when prompted a human into
solving captures for it well that may no
longer be needed it solves this one
pretty easily so no captures are not
going to slow down gpt4 next medical
imagery it was able to interpret this
complex image and spot elements of a
brain tumor now it did not spot the full
diagnosis but I want to point something
out this paper from openai was released
only a few days ago and it tested gpt4
on medical questions they found that
gpd4 can attain outstanding results
exceeding Human Performance levels and
that that was without Vision the images
and graphs were not passed to the model
and as you can see when the questions
did have media in them it brought down
gpd4's average it will be very
interesting to see GPT 4's results when
its multimodal capabilities are
accounted for next is humor and I'm not
showing these to say that they're
necessarily going to change the world
but it does demonstrate the raw
intellect of gpt4 to suss out why these
images are funny you have to have quite
a nuanced understanding of humanity
let's just say that it probably
understood this meme quicker than I did
quick thing to point out by the way it
won't do faces for pretty obvious
privacy reasons they won't allow the
model to recognize cases whether that
ability gets jailbreaked only time will
tell meanwhile it can read menus and
interpret the physical world which is an
amazing asset for visually impaired
people I want to move on to another
fascinating ability that the vision
model inside gpd4 possesses and that is
reading graphs and text from images its
ability to interpret complex diagrams
and captions is going to change the
world here it is understanding a complex
diagram and caption from the palm e
paper released only about three weeks
ago which I have done a video on by the
way but just how good is it at reading
text from an image well let's take a
look at gpt4's score on the text vqa
Benchmark now I've covered quite a few
of the other benchmarks in other videos
but I want to focus on this one here
notice how gpt4 got 78 which is better
than the previous state of the art model
which got 72 now try to remember that 78
figure what exactly is this testing you
ask well really text from complex images
this is the original text vqa academic
paper and you can see some of the sample
questions above to be honest if you want
to test your own eyesight you can try
them yourself so how does the average
human perform well on page seven we have
this table and we get this figure for
humans 85 you don't need me to tell you
that's just seven percent better than
gpt4 the thing is though these models
aren't slowing down as the vision
co-lead at openai put it scale is all
you need until everyone else realizes it
too but the point of this video is to
show you the improvements in one area
are starting to bleed into improvements
in other areas we already saw that an
image of bad handwriting could be
translated into a website as you can see
here even badly written natural language
can now be translated directly into code
in blender creating detailed 3D models
with fascinating physics the borders of
text image 3D and embodiment are
beginning to be broken down and of
course other companies are jumping into
here's Adobe showing how you can edit 3D
images using text and how long will it
really be before we go direct from text
to physical models all mediated through
natural language and it's not just about
creating 3D it's about interacting with
it through text notice how we can pick
out both text and higher level Concepts
like objects this dense 3D field was
captured using 2D images from a phone
this paper was released only 10 days ago
but notice how now we have a language
embedded inside the model we can search
and scan for more abstract Concepts like
yellow or even utensils or electricity
it's not perfect and for some reason it
really struggled with recognizing Ramen
but it does represent state-of-the-art
image into 3D interpreted through text
but what if you don't even want to type
you just want to use your voice just
three weeks ago I did a video on how
voice recognition will change everything
and I was talking about open ai's
whisper API but now we have conformer
which is better than whisper here is the
chart to prove it and look how conformer
makes fewer errors even than whisper at
recognizing speech the cool thing is you
can test it for yourself and the link is
in the description and while you're
passing by the description don't forget
to leave a like and a comment to let me
know if you've learned anything from
this video as you'd expect I tested it
myself and it did amazingly at
transcribing my recent video on gpt4
there were only a handful of mistakes in
a 12 minute transcript at this point
you're probably thinking what's next
well look at the roots sketched out two
years ago by Sam Altman he said in the
next five years computer programs that
can think will read legal documents and
give medical advice with gpt4 passing
the bar I would say so far he's two for
two he goes on in the next decade they
will do assembly line work and maybe
even become companions he's talking
about the physical embodiment of
language models back then openai had a
robotics team themselves that could do
things like this here is a robotic hand
solving a Rubik's Cube is despite
interruptions from a giraffe and someone
putting a pen to interrupt the model it
still solved the cube but then that team
got disbanded and it seems like they've
moved into investing in startups they
are leading a 23 million dollar
investment in 1X a startup developing a
human-like robot here is the One X
website and it features this rather
startling image and it says summer 2023
our newest Android iteration Neo will
explore how artificial intelligence can
take form in a human-like body now of
course for many of you a humanoid robot
won't be that surprising here is the
obligatory clip from Boston Dynamics
foreign
thank you
and of course these models don't have to
be humanoid here is a demonstration from
a paper published just four days ago
this is not just walking it's climbing
up balancing pressing and operating
buttons and before you think all of this
is really far away these assembly line
robots are now commercially available I
still think there's a long way to go
before embodiment becomes mainstream but
my point is this all these improvements
that we're seeing in text audio 3D and
embodiment they're starting to merge
into each other complement each other on
their own they're cool and a bit nerdy
but once they start synergizing fusing
together they could be revolutionary as
samuelman said on the Lex Friedman
podcast released yesterday embodiment
might not be needed for AGI but it's
coming anyway let me know what you think
in the comments and have a wonderful day